Dave moody was the guy that Paulie
suggested we talked to known as the
Godfather he lives at the tracks lead
turn announcer for motor racing Network
joining us from Talladega Dave thanks
for joining us on short notice
give us a set well let me let me start
with the obvious the reaction when you
heard about this yesterday afternoon or
last night with the news found that
bubble Wallace's garage
well horrified certainly is the is the
first knee-jerk reaction as a member of
the NASCAR family the NASCAR community I
would say there's a certain factor of
embarrassment here despite the fact that
we don't know yet who's responsible for
this you know it's been it's become a
very much a front burner topic in the
recent weeks and despite you know 60 odd
years in this sport battling with the
different elements and facets of racism
boy it's become hot burner here lately
and it and it clearly is flushing a lot
of people with antiquated views out of
the shadows in a big time way here over
the last few days take me into the
garage is there this setup that Bubba
Bubba Wallace would have and then who
has access to them it's very different
sense coded 19 than it has been a year
ago this weekend there would have been
literally thousands of people in the
garage fans and sponsor representatives
in the light this year with the COBIT 19
shut down there's a very finite number
of people to have access to the garage
seats race teens you know obviously race
team members working on all those race
cars there are there are track personnel
there you know people that have to empty
the garbage cans and and the like
there's law enforcement there's emergent
emergency medical people on and NASCAR
officials certainly but it's a a pretty
finite number of people compared to what
it would have been a year ago I don't
know about do teams have their own
security for their their cars and what
is Talladega offer that they really
don't the tracks provide security
obviously the the garage areas are
fenced off there is considerably more
space between the actual team
this year then there has been in the
past because they've gone to every other
garage stall and over help with the
social distancing but the tracks are
responsible for cordoning off those
areas the garages are generally and I
can't say in every case but they are
generally locked up after the garage
closes and the teams go home for the
night
who might have access during those you
know after-hours times I don't know I'm
reasonably confident though that that
with the assistance of video cameras and
the light we're going to find out but do
we know like this does that as NASCAR
even announced that they have cameras
here I haven't seen anything or heard
anything but I don't know if they have
coverage of the exterior of these
garages or interiors yeah I don't know
exactly what they have available to them
I know that that NASCAR is a sanctioning
body travels with a lot of video
coverage to keep an eye on things that
are going on in the garage quite
honestly I don't know the extent of that
and very few people do know the extent
of that and that's kind of the idea
NASCAR in a kind of modified Big Brother
approach they don't want these race
teams to think that nobody's looking and
nobody's seeing what they're doing to
these race cars at any time during the
course of the weekend so I'm reasonably
confident without knowing the specifics
that that they're going to have some
video footage to look at what's the
weather gonna be like and Talladega I
don't know you know it was a 20% chance
of rain yesterday the rain moved in
about two hours before race time and it
just never let up the forecast for today
is not as good as it was yesterday but
I'll say this mother nature has not been
a friend of ours this year we were
supposed to rain out for more farm or up
and then we were supposed to race and
what we've had a few of those this year
more than we would like we've also got a
few in that the weather guessers didn't
think we had a chance at so we'll see
this is a hate crime you know Dave I
think somebody should go to go to jail
for this
whoever it is I don't know that they
said well maybe it's an inside job I I
mean to me I don't care if it it it's
unless it's somebody on Bubba's team you
know if it's an inside
job you know that they should go to jail
for this yeah I I agree with you
wholeheartedly and and I know what this
you know at a time like this it's hard
to look at a situation like this as
anything positive but in a in a
backhanded sort of way it is in the last
two or three weeks we in the NASCAR
community have been able to to look at
our circle of friends and realize with a
great degree of certainty that some of
them are dinosaurs and some of them are
still in the 1800's and some of them are
up until very recently closeted racists
and every opportunity we get to weed
them out even if it's one by one or one
a week or one a month it's still one
fewer than we had when we started so I
guess that's the the upside to all of us
yeah and I hear people and you've spent
your life in this sport Dave you know I
just do drive-bys with this you know I'm
curious and I like the personalities and
we have a lot of those guys as guests
but you know when somebody says well it
did nascar finally got rid of the
confederate flag I look at it is I don't
yes could we have done it before but we
but they did it like that that's
progress that you did it and here we are
talking about this I mean you probably
didn't think there would be a day maybe
in your lifetime that that Confederate
flag would not be flying inside a track
that's right it's been very slow to
happen it's taken far far too long
you know NASCAR is still a predominantly
an overwhelmingly white male sport even
in comparison to other branches of
Motorsports NASCAR remains a white male
sport they're working awfully hard to
change that they've made some terrific
progress Bubba Wallace is certainly an
example of that so the fact that it's
taken too long is sad but the fact that
it's finally happening it's been it's
been a cataclysmic last couple of months
for our sport between Kobuk 19 and all
of the Confederate flag discussion and
debates it's been it's been a tsunami
really that's overtaken this sport and
and I don't think we've seen the last of
it yet yeah you know NASCAR's got to get
NASCAR like baseball you have an older
your your fan base is older I you know
NASCAR's partnering with barstools
sports to try to get younger you would
think you would be trumpeting Bubba
Wallace here's a good-looking guy not
afraid to stand up speak his mind this
is the future that's a whole different
fan base and and hopefully NASCAR is
looking at it that way and I'm I'm
watching today but I'm watching for
Bubba Wallace III and I hope the hell he
wins so I understand that completely and
and you're right it's a mystery to me
that corporate America has not yet found
a reason and an excuse to step up and
get behind hey Bubba Wallace with
everything positive that he has going
for him and quite honestly there are no
negatives with Bubba Wallace and then
you factor him in with Richard Petty you
know with the hat and the sunglass is
the most recognizable personality in the
history of our sport you know he's our
Muhammad Ali you could you could send
him to whose Becca stamp and so to him
in the airport and ask him for his
autograph so it's a it's baffling to me
that nobody in corporate America really
has seen fit to any great degree to get
behind this young man but I'm hopeful
that this may change maybe for all the
wrong reasons
but but the end result may turn out to
be right Dave thanks for joining us and
good luck this afternoon we appreciate
your time I understand at Steve moody
lead turn announcer for motor racing
Network host of Sirius XM Speedway on
Sirius XM the NASCAR radio Channel